[Applause]
do you remember when you're 12 you will
ideal all to a mission to which the
right choice the world armin en 2013
together with most pieces of table he
studied must my in bali the cash registers a
problem
the row city had an easy solution  to take
minutes santing that the green
goblin as plastic pollution and home
island bali indonesia
nou
my first art the end landlord by
james wicker hak de std hi introduce
myself
and she found he no [ __ ] and movement
builder
what was nou is delivered with such
conference
er  is the cs50 new box and wine emergency
idea
now familiarize
starred in full fashion and i regret with
experience we de qi plus change and
matching bali passing by free de for
sandra was over and the school
started here and andrew migrants everything with guts
oh so  cute zo inspirational
en yes hai just too little girls en de
band je fans trying to make a difference
is for the special bij noa
chad was really what was going for a
slower
to buil  d it i think a the rapid and
screen camping de bellehoeve it te
stiens beach clean-up collection in the
shirt secretly public and the politicians
de moer island
the more and one and teams te ching
bag
gigi students upsessions and my change
the app ns quickly  as expected it 14
years old
entangle cell death deep in my soul and
soon after there in my first iris of
highschool
experience my vers for now but having
said a and wooden of change de ving
especialy pas in 2019 bali findin am
single is stuck i grab my  views and aj
you can do this online journey outside of
the traditional crippler
and cross for building a om during a
free market duncan charme so what the
next up shabby
had the continue building the momentum we
needed to achieve the change you want to
see someone to  love life lessons very
quickly and yet narsingh die was zo
minecraft hobby there again back when are
starting
first
change so na have a as quickly as
summer vacation
it gives a nice time  and that makes
sense easy to accept that is why it is
essential
the criticism legal
with the tumor or so
ethics sale other people
justin and be open to learn
with co2 emission and how the vossen had within
so hopeful then navigate
collaborations with businesses and
politicians
someone  has to just a left in the room
and finally
is also hot sign brick and step back
for second
the armenia was undefined
how we continue to work by us and
recharge cd milly was department him
follows a younger and younger
116 euro
9:45 ter  world where all the fuckboys'
missing school
crafting manifesto
organizing demonstrations trillion dollar
coin and corporation sidewalk sign of using
to wait until below to start making
a difference
and peter changemaker
is not something any body has an ad
baker knife it's a stumping twin set
fire to become  one they grow it
something much happens
something activation
and experience and injustice dat ik
s'pose big or small local of global and
then there i  s om us no choice but i get
in golft in de la muscle is on him spend
more time in otherwise gotham's ben in
my own shine principles of leadership
sustainability and change my skills and
items en met consultant at young people
ar eat in wasted and knowledge  pamela
him too active active 3d
glasses change and start in class
with class him heaven increasingly distant
relationship with to reality
high peak it is high time
twincer the popular in the cosmos
reflect what is happening outsider of
and then sir dat every single student in
every corner of the world has at least
one hour idea of mandatory lessons that
the clamps prices the mood
kinesthetic and about any sustainable
innovations and butter realities if you
send this world of 10 billion you your
graduation and that no one ever as
strongly believe the every young  person
can be teaching speaker
the department helps you knowing where and
how to start and molenwiek voor de kas grant
him that people know my piercing  to
create or online journey
that is lifestyle and network kon de
circle of you would in youtube via the
platform voor jong change wikkers to
learn from each other
mini de role models and also the stories
with an impact realizing samples remember
weekend ik action en minutes cyrus  storm
keep our age
eye wish i were known refugee educator
mohammed al john d van syria 3 printer
and entrepeneur philips finds pillar of
germany and gender equality activist
parties million thai family lisa because
who was [ __ ] god and how is that club
in able to jump on  a call it come and
join us and experiences
nou f te aan that must de weiss and you are
single a new scary tram house as
east and its best way to describe it
is made to refer to the word
greenwashing
now walnut is the processor could think
fixed  impression that the climate fund
minus
other company car auctions
wi-fi have a long moment is something
i call us washing now by montuno the
emails and a process week and on  a daily
base is of companies around us for
anything that
some artistic box and sociable
and activist since the good for business
although the intention where i extend to
be good for climate team zo
to the company is used wash and arm  en tc
setting bids for the photo was
en je pas or recession john de brainstorm
earrings
when the in channel workshops who knows
maybe you buy this to review board
meetings and a fresh fresh van meurs
mentoring sessions
you might be surprised
all grab it the last  hangars and soul
intense journey from my young to go to
the changemaker for the mains plug
and collective labor agreement generation that is rising leading
by example and taking action
teacher activism is more than and
inspiration
bouchard serious about change do you think
[Music]